[Music]
well like all obedient americans who are
pretty
dialed into what the cdc has to say
about our lives every day we check for
new guidance and we have new guidance
for once it has nothing to do with the
coronavirus
this guidance from the cdc is about
chickens
the cdc is warning americans about
chickens and we're quoting now
don't kiss or snuggle backyard poultry
and don't eat or drink around them end
quote
now that raises the question who are
these chicken touchers out there that
the cdc is concerned about and we're not
judging us we ask that we just
would like to know are there people in
this country snuggle chickens
there are and again not judging we found
one here she is
my name is tara i'm 27 and i'm a chicken
enthusiast
i love you so much my chickens are like
my babies since i don't have human
babies
these are my human babies i have one
special chicken her name is sheila
she stays in my room with me she does
everything with me
this is sheila this is my one true love
ben's pretty cute do you think he likes
chickens
tara solem is the chicken enthusiast you
just saw we're happy to have her on
tonight
tara thanks so much for coming on oh
what that's a that's a good-looking bird
so how do you it feels like you've been
singled out by the cdc for criticism how
does that feel
you know i'm not a huge fan of it
because i've been
handling chickens since i was about four
years old and i've been kissing them
snuggling them shoving my face in them
and
i'm fine people around me are fine and
i don't see a problem with it
i mean people you're living the way
people used to live i mean
human beings have a long history with
poultry it's a domesticated animal right
why do you think there's there's the
concern now
why are they coming after you now the
cdc
i think that maybe they're just looking
for something else to control
and i'm not a huge fan and i don't
support it so
i'm just gonna keep doing what i'm doing
i'm going to keep loving on my birds and
showing them my affection
tell us what you are doing with those
birds i mean does the
does that bird who is that is that
sheila
no no no this is not sheila uh this is
bad boy halo
this is one of my roosters that i
hatched back in february
and he basically just makes me babies
and he's a real important
in my flock what what
kind of pet does he make i mean for
people who are thinking
you know people think of chickens as
eggs and dinner
you're describing a whole new way of
looking at chickens are they good pets
i fully support everybody owning a
chicken in their lifetime
they are way smarter than people give
them credit for
they have facial recognition they
know exactly who i am when i pull up to
my house um
they're just all around great pets they
have amazing personalities
and people are over here saying that
they're dumb and stupid and
they're not not even for a second
so i got to ask you since you're an
enthusiast and an expert
someone was told me that chickens are so
dumb if you face them in a corner they
can't get out
is that true whoever made that up
has something against birds and it's not
true at all they know exactly what to do
sometimes they get stuck in corners but
for the most part they can figure it out
how many you're totally winning me over
by the way i'm just gonna be
honest about it how many chickens do you
have
i have 30.
do you live in a rural area yeah so i
live
out kind of more towards the outskirts
of the
city and i have about 22 acres there
with all of them
living there with me are those last
question are these house birds i mean
i'm trying not to ask do they sleep on
the bed but i'll just ask do they sleep
on the bed
so when i have like chicks when i've
hatched chicks i
have been known to bring them inside
i'll like roll them up in a towel
and they'll sleep next to me and it will
be like a chicken burrito
and sometimes they'll come inside like
if i need to give them a bath or clean
them or stuff but
they're pretty comfortable inside
i'm such a believer tara thank you so
much for coming on tonight that was
great
good to see you you are so welcome thank
you for having me
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else